نا اياكمعم
وله الفضل وله الثنا والحسنخلصين
له الدينكرين
كفا
الله لا اله الا هو
الذي يش
لا بين
اللهم جنا اللهم من
[Silence]
الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
ان شاء الله تعالى
كتاب الوجيز في فقه السنه والكتاب العزيز
‏Bantidران
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الشيخ البدوي رحمه الله
‏Fasting رمضان
is no different than any other
act of worship in Islam
in the sense that the schar
of Islam
in order for students to be able to
digest
‏If
things
will
scattered for theage student theage
person to be able toeh them all
however this categorization and when we
say categories what I speaking
‏I'm talking about categorization
such as
the category of conditions.
‏areillar are
for
dig
to
صلى الله عليه وسلمحب
رضي الله عنهم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
فما اتاكم الرسول فخذوه
وما نهاكم عنه فانتهوا
[Silence]
مستحب
حرام مكروه
‏proply
categorization of this isat this is
you know this is this is مستحب this is
this is this
‏comm
to comp by
was
her
comp
‏did whatever not do and if we hold that
and if we learn that
which is something that sounds
common sense of course a
Muslim does that no if we learn that I
going to teach
‏as
did
not wor about
[Silence]
ரض
‏all knowledge and anyciine
is in categories
let say I want to learn mathematic
well I can't just learn
just go wild and and start taking random
problems and and just solving them no I
have to categor my learning so I make
categories I say this
‏take
one number and add to another and there
take away there divion and there
multiplication oppos right and build on
that categor
is knowledge
is categored
by
it can be more easily digable
‏asigations
as
andarn those that is not to bas ouration
فما اتاكم الرسول
فخذوه
وما نهاكم عنه فانته
رمضان
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ر
منها اربعه حرم الشهر الحرام بالشهر
الحرام
رمضان
قال الله تعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا كتب
الصيام
كما كتب على الذين من قبلكم لعلكم تتقون
الله
شهر رمضان الذي انزل فيه القران هدى للناس
وبينات من الهدى والفرقان
[Silence]
فمن شهد منكم الشهر فليصم
وعن ابن عمر رضي الله عنه قال قال رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم بني الاسلام على
خمس شهاده ان لا اله الا الله وان محمدا
رسول الله واقام الصلاه وايتاء الزكاه
والحج وحج البيت وصوم رمضان متفق عليه
بخاري مسلم عبد الله بن عمر
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
زكاهزك
الله
رمضان
يقول المؤلف واجمعت الامه على وجوب صيام
‏agaman
الاسلام
التي علمت من بالضروره
وان منكره كافر مرتد عن الاسلام
الشيخ سيد سابق رحمه الله فقه السنه
[Silence]
فقهاء
يعني المعلوم بالضروره
فقه
‏needid
beond needid
among thees
of
just fire isotes everyone here know
that everyone here
received that mo that fire is hot if i
say what's youridence that fire is
‏that
rises from the east and west
if we needid for that you're dealing
with someone who either insane or blind
right this is beyond needing
individualidence if iish the paper right
in scientific america tomorrow on
fire is actually hot would that
معلوم من الدين بالضروره
حلال
حلال ربا حرام
حرام
‏Musl
by way of common knowledge in Islam and
this is the highest highest highest
levels of of
something being affirmed as being a
ruling
اسلام
يقول عن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه قال قال
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم من صام
رمضان ايمانا واحتسابا غفر له ما تقدم من
ذنبه الله اكبر بخاري مسلم
ابو هريره
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
رمضان
ايمانا واحتسابا
الله اكبر
ايمانا واحتسابا ايمانا
يعني طاعه لله وايمانا بوجوبه وبفضله
واحتسابا
يعني تشوفا الاجر من الله وان يحتسب الاجر
عند الله سبحانه وتعالى
رمضان
[Silence]
وعن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه ان رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم قال قال الله عز وجل
كل عمل ابن ادم له الا الصيام فانه لي
وانا اجزي به والصيام جنه فاذا كان يوم
صوم احدكم فلا يرفث ولا يصخب ولا يجهل فان
شاتمه احد او قاتله فليقل اني صائم مرتين
يعني اني صائم اني صائم والذي نفس محمد
بيده لخلوف فم الصائم اطيب عند الله يوم
القيامه من ريح المسك خلوف فم الصائم يعني
رائحه فم الصائم الذي يصدر من الجوف حين
الصيام قال وللصائم فرحتان يفرحهما
اذا افطر فرح بفطره واذا لقي ربه فرح
بصومه متفق عليه وس
ان شاء الله تعالى ذسين اف صلاه العشاء
عشاء خاطره نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه
وكرمه وجوده ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان
ينفعنا بما علمنا وان يزيدنا علما وان
يبلغنا رمضان وان يوفقنا لصيامه وقيامه
ايمانا واحتسابا واتباعا لرسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم والله اعلم وصلى صلى الله
وسلم على نبينا